la pétanque c'est aussi une affaire de
femmes dans le club de montigny le
bretonneux
c'est du sérieux gers et aujourd'hui
enfin comme en compétition
c'est l'exercice de tir de précision
là on va jouer contre toute la région
ile de france après c'est pour ça qu'on
a pu venir en place un coach pour qu'il
puisse nous aider à monter et à
progresser
l'équipe féminine a remporté le
championnat interclubs des yvelines de
elles sont qualifiées pour la deuxième
division régionale il fallait donc
passer à la vitesse supérieure pour
cette année 2010 8
elles se sont très vite très bien
entendu et le fait qu' il y ait
quelqu'un qui vienne un petit peu on va
dire les coachs et entre guillemets au
départ
ça leur a fait du bien alors j'en
donnais des conseils au départ juste
comme ça mais qu'après bas m'ont appelé
coach alors dombasle jeudi aux agapes
on va s'occuper d'elle et pour aller le
plus loin possible l'équipe à sa botte
secrète
la benjamine de l'équipe à 19 ans elle a
terminé vice championne départementale
en tête à tête l'année dernière ce qui
lui a valu le titre de meilleur espoir
féminin de la ville de montigny le
bretonneux parler puis à la rencontre
d'anciens amis puis lui joue a prétendu
coup ce premier rendez vous de ce
championnat interclubs régional pour les
femmes le 29 septembre
elles affronteront l'équipe de mesnil le
roi